- wha
don't change the world
what I'm gonna first do is just kind of
set this up quickly a lot of you are
familiar with kind of the global impact
and their trends but essentially three
phenomena I'm occurring right both
economic where the developed economies
of established countries is intersecting
with more developing economies and I'll
get into that in a second
social demographics there's countries
that are aging and shrinking and others
that are have experiencing hyper growth
and then the environmental is why we're
here we spend a lot of time on that and
so just a snapshot you know and give me
some backdrop you know aging populations
in the United States and China Japan
South Korea etc and shrinking
populations in Germany Russia mostly in
Europe we coupled with kind of hyper
growth right India obviously and in
Africa and so it's interesting this
phenomena is occurring as you know as
most of the people now more than half
the world's population is is being
urbanized and where is this urbanization
occurring and where the trends and
innovations transpiring so I just want
to give you some background on that on
the technology side whole host of
phenomenon happening right within social
networking mobile cloud the Internet of
Things I'll get into in a second and
talk about that a little bit and then
pervasive video when you think about it
the brains cortex has 30 percent of it
is dedicated to vision eight and six
percent is dedicated to touch and and
hearing and so sixty percent of
communication is nonverbal so pervasive
video is a key theme around how people
learn live work and play and that is a
trend that we're seeing as a huge
momentum shifter within these these
smart cities if you will and so I
mentioned the Internet of Things what
does that really mean it's not a cisco
terminology is really I think coined by
a McKinsey and some others but
essentially it's everything's going to
be connected and so if you look today
there are twice as many devices
connected to the Internet as there are
people and
the belief is and a trend is going that
by 2020 will have more than 50 billion
devices connected devices being could be
sensors in your automobile on your
telling you what your tire gauge
pressure is to smart IDs on produce in a
refrigerator that if you want to make a
a meal you know what's in there knots in
there to sensors that are on water waste
management systems everything will be
connected in the Internet is an
important aspect that so these trends we
view lead to smart things for smart
cities so what's a smart thing so a
little cartoon a little joke here but at
the end of the day it's a little bit of
processing power a smart thing can
exhibit interesting behaviors if there's
they're networked
to something else and what we mean by
that is a smart thing is less about a
human being
interacting with that thing it's machine
to machine and so what's happening is
sensors need to talk to other sensors
with outcomes that we think will create
greater efficiencies from an energy
perspective to experiences on how you
interact with systems and so when we say
smart things we mean machine to machine
and the network connecting the two so if
we take smart things and we go into
smart cities we've worked with Forrester
and others in looking at okay we can
have technology till technologies sake
and make things really smart and
efficient but the fundamental things I
think it was discussed earlier today was
around governance and city system
initiatives and so the upper right-hand
quadrant were cities that we saw that
had both ingredients both Barcelona New
York etc and they come in all shapes and
sizes and and one of the phenomenon that
we're seeing is smart cities are less
about the large big cities while density
is on their side and density is very
helpful in kind of adoption of new
systems the integration of disparate
systems are challenging for cities that
are over 10 million people or more the
sweet spot we think is about a hundred
thousand to about a million people
Barcelona is about a million people and
so what we see is the adoption of smart
grid alternative energy capabilities
transportation systems in a holistic
manner
seemed to be you know accelerating a
quicker pace in that hundred thousand to
a million person city or community not
that they're not accelerating in the
large cities but they're more segmented
and so if you have a smart city what do
you need well you need a strategy and
what our experience has been on the
ground is that if you have a vision and
a strategy around how do you make a
smart community from the beginning those
are the ones that are more successful
and what we we don't call it coin this
term it's an industry term is
information communication technology
technology historically has been thought
about as an afterthought and if it's an
afterthought it's a retrofit if it's a
retrofit its cost prohibitive and it
doesn't happen and it's not market
driven so we fundamentally believe and
we have been successful on a lot of
these communities that I'll get into in
a second on proof points is that if
there's a strategy around technology to
do two basic things create efficiencies
and create new revenue streams because
if we can create efficiencies then the
developer the equity investor and the
construction management company buy into
the ability that says there's it
operational savings on energy downstream
but what's more important to them is
that can I reduce first cost on the
second piece is that there's an
operational efficiency play and we're
driving and consuming less energy
there's potentially new revenue streams
and I'll get into that in a second so
how do we respond and I alluded to this
a little bit there isn't one stakeholder
there's multiple stakeholders and my
experience has been in working on
projects in Korea and China and in
Europe and Latin America is you need
people not just one but multiple people
have the vision around the outcome that
you want to create the strategy that I
just alluded to global standards are
critical you can't have proprietary
systems that don't talk to each other
the second is regulation I think it was
discussed earlier today regulation will
drive a lot of this concept around smart
grids and around the delivery of energy
in an efficient manner that is hugely
wasteful today and I think last year you
talked about public-private partnerships
but our experience is that if the
government needs to be on board with
private developers
the spirit of public-private
partnerships for these communities to
work and lastly as an ecosystem a new
ecosystem who to think that you know IBM
or Cisco or any other technology
companies would really be relevant in
urbanization and and what we think is
technology is a key catalyst to driving
energy consumption down and efficiencies
up in these in these developing
communities so I'm going quickly here
and the reason I'm done was given 20
minutes so I'm gonna race through this
in a second then I'll get to the proof
points but why did Cisco get into this
why why Cisco is involved in this and
back with President Clinton on the
Clinton Global Initiative the challenge
was carbon reduction that was kind of
the challenge in Cisco's looking at its
portfolio of its product solutions and
ecosystem to to complement that around
directly indirectly and systemically
affecting that and what has happened is
we've taken that initiative from 2006
2008 and we've embarked on really a
campaign that we call smart connected
communities and it's a practice that I'm
a part of and run around focusing on the
three key tenets around social
environmental and economic
sustainability what is interesting is if
you don't get the economics right and I
think it was discussed before if it's
not market driven the environmental
capabilities that we have as
technologists and as city planners
around the globe will never be realized
and the outcome that you really want to
create is a social environment that
promotes inclusion entrepreneurship new
business models new revenue streams but
you'll never get there if you can't get
past the first piece which is the
economic play and when you might say
well what is a service and actually hey
if you got an economic play what are you
actually delivering and what Cisco looks
at it is two basic areas one is you hear
a lot of things about a cloud a cloud is
nothing more than a big data center or
collection of Technology and and
componentry that sits in a data center
cloud somewhere we call that the
community exchange a common fabric of an
open standard to facilitate these kinds
of these technologies and then the
outcome which is really around a
community connect offering and the best
analogy I can give
you is if you look at kind of the
structure or the framework that we
talked about I won't go through this
slide and the easiest way to to to
describe it is foundationally I think of
an iPhone as a platform right so an
iPhone is a platform and foundationally
in network as a platform and then
there's an app store by which is open to
third-party developers to develop
applications and services and so that
app store is kind of the middle layer
and cisco is developing a service
delivery platform by which third-party
developers can build applications and
services that you might want to consume
for different experiences and so our
belief is that if there's a foundational
layer with this software intelligence
and working closely with IBM on a lot of
this work then we'll deliver outcomes we
can create new revenue streams that get
people on board with looking at
alternative ways of producing delivering
and disseminating energy as an example
so the financial modeling is critical
and so what Cisco is done is we have put
together a framework and an approach in
a small consulting practice whether it's
done by us or others it doesn't really
matter the bottom line is if you have a
plan it needs to be driven by a
financial model around a community in a
holistic manner and if you can't show a
return on any kind of investment whether
that is public or private investments
the project usually never goes anywhere
and so we look at this as a phenomenal
opportunity because if you look at a
building what is it 50% of the world's
population is urbanized seventy-five
percent of the world's energy is
consumed by cities 48% of which is
consumed by buildings that are only 40
percent efficient so ours is less of
this game around from from our vantage
point around developing new ways of
consuming energy it's around an
efficiency play how do we get disparate
systems to talk to one another and so
with the exception of lifes you know
fire alarm safety systems that they need
to be dedicated these other systems
there's no reason why they should not be
connecting and talking to one another so
we can reduce first cost and create
greater efficiencies and consume less
energy while offering a platform for new
kinds of services
so some of the proof points and I'll
slow down on this piece on the proof
points we break this into very targeted
areas case studies around Cisco on Cisco
or finite or very distinct kind of
opportunities such as stadiums around
around the planet to greenfield
development to revitalizations and we
have a whole host of proof points I'll
dive into about three or four of them
and one in particular is in Amsterdam
and in South Korea this concept of smart
work centres and so this concept was
really born by the traffic congestion in
Amsterdam and rather than commute to
compute you want to go to places where
you're collaborating with your
colleagues and other constituents to
conduct business and so we formulated a
strategy that created these basically
smart work centers that have immersive
video pervasive technology where that
will allow individuals to work in a more
collaborative way without having to
travel halfway across town
South Korea's picked up on this and
they're having actually deploying 500 of
these and the lessons learned whereas
it's just not about work but it's also
around incubation collaboration and
community centers and so they've
expanded the strategy to do not just
that but also how to fuse the new
developments in the Incheon area with
the existing developments in the broader
South Korea area so Songdo South Korea
project I've been intimately involved
with 1,500 acres of reclaimed land from
the ground up so the asset is you've got
virgin land the challenges you have
virgin land so this has been a 10-year
project we've been involved with it for
the last five years it's a little over
30 percent complete almost 50 percent
complete and I would say that the
lessons learned there is that have a
plan and a strategy and an execution
around sustainability cogeneration is
delivering the energy throughout the the
community they have a pneumatic waste
system there's no garbage trucks on the
streets so pneumatic waste is is pulled
in two vacuum tubes under the community
in the city renewable
on water waste management so they
reclaim about 70% of the rainwater and
put it back into irrigation there's a
whole host whole host of different
sustainability approaches that they've
taken that have been quite successful
and location is key they are located 15
minutes from the Incheon Airport that
can get to one-third of the world's
population in a three-hour flight so the
goal here the theme for this community
is how do I get foreign investment to
take up space in this community such
that this could potentially be the new
gateway to the East from Northeast Asia
perspective and I would say the lessons
learned have been working closely with
the government and the private developer
Gale international and POSCO and see is
that the free economic zone incentives
to have corporations come here we're not
fully solidified and I think are still
developing so I think if if the
government could have worked more
collaboratively with really outlining
that quicker you would probably get more
corporations coming they are now but
it's taken some time Barcelona
another project that again what they
have done is a revitalization project
where they have taking existing systems
and connected them both transportation
and energy and what lessons learned on
this one is they're taking their lessons
learned packaging up and creating a
separate entity to export this knowledge
and export this knowledge in a fee based
consulting arrangement and it's
basically a government entity that's
been set up as a special purpose vehicle
by which to create revenue for Barcelona
I have two more and then I'll wrap up
here in the United States
Chicago Lakeside is a project that we've
been involved with that is 600 acres
eight miles south of Chicago on Lake
Michigan it used to be a u.s. steel
plant and when they closed the the plant
30,000 jobs were lost what I would say
the lessons learned on this project is
the developer McCaffery interest has
done a phenomenal job of including
experts around water waste management
energy transportation technology and
have engaged us in a very robust
manor with the with the urban planning
design firm Skidmore Owings Merrill who
are looking at innovative ways to drive
energy consumption down and in the
ability to use water in a more
meaningful way the idea is is for not
just to implement these technologies but
actually through Argonne National Labs
and others to create a living lab in
this community to test out these kinds
of new technologies as we speak and the
last one is Scavo outside of Moscow and
what they are doing is they are
leveraging a lot of expertise in the
energy space and yes some of that energy
is nuclear some of it is biomass etc and
what we're finding is that they're
trying to take their assets around
energy and create really an incubation
or an innovation hub around energy
consumption and what's interesting is
cisco has worked very closely with them
to provide the communications
infrastructure for the delivery of that
of that of really that innovation hub if
you will
I lied this is the last one so the
Metropolitan Transit Authority in New
York City has taken a very surgical
approach in transportation systems and
looked at for delivering basically
wayfinding capabilities through
interface information kiosks right and
so to navigate through the New York City
subway system can be challenging for a
visitor and these have been hugely
successful such that they are starting
to connect to other systems such as the
bus such as the traffic systems etc
throughout the New York City area and
the only thing that I would share with
you at the end of this is and I gave you
a snippet of some of the proof points
some of our experiences that innovation
is key it's an overused word but it
can't be pushed aside so the quotas are
if you can't read it says your proposal
is innovative unfortunately we won't be
able to use it because we've never tried
something like that before you've got to
try new things think different I'm
stealing this from Apple but the ideas
around aligning with the key
stakeholders looking at these concept of
living labs and communities because we
don't have
all the answers we have some of the
answers and evolve our thinking as we go
so I just wanted to share some of my
perspectives with you hopefully that was
helpful well there's another world
population as far as the the medium size
so our estimation is about 1/3 of the
world's population is in that sweet spot
and so what we have found and it's
focused on is that not that we've been
looking at the big cities but that's
about a third of the world's population
is in that's change the world